just this week we took action to protect
a workers right to overtime this is an
issue of basic fairness if you work
longer you work harder you should get
paid for it today some companies take
advantage of an exception in the rule to
make their lower wage employees who
really should be paid hourly they're
making them work 50 60 sometimes 70
hours a week without paying them an
extra dime in extreme cases as possible
for workers actually earn less than the
minimum wage so they essentially label
somebody as management instead of a
worker even if they're making like
$25,000 working a whole bunch hours
that's a way of getting around the
minimum wage it's not fair so we're
updating the rules we're ending that
except we're making more workers
eligible for the overtime that you've
earned as one of the single most
important steps we can take to help grow
middle-class wages it's going to give as
many as five million Americans including
80,000 folks right here in Wisconsin the
overtime protections they deserve